are you filming me okay karen
hi my name is karen hi i'm karen
my name is karen or as my mother calls
me garden
and yes i have definitely seen the karen
meme and i'm
here what's a karen
why is it everywhere and where did it
come from
this is the origin of the karen mean
[Music]
when most people think of karen an image
of a white lady with kate gosselin's
2008 haircut comes to mind the moon has
evolved from someone entitled
who has a specific style haircut and
always wants to speak to the manager if
they don't get their way
um to something a little more complex
and higher stakes karen has come to
represent
a white entitled woman who is capable of
causing harm
to people around her in particular
people of color so they tried to walk
right here and she blocked them
get oxen yell at me some more
a hysterical middle-aged woman with a
complete lack of awareness of her
privilege
why is karen middle-aged well the name's
fallen in popularity
as of 2018 it sits at 637th for u.s girl
names
karen was consistently in the top 10
list in the 50s and 60s
so today there are a lot of karen's in
their 50s and 60s
growing up it seemed like all of my
friends parents were named karen
my teacher was named karen i didn't know
a single other karen
my age but why aren't we dissing other
names of that era why not linda or
susan there are some theories on why
this name in particular became the
inspiration for this character archetype
some redditors point to ray liotta
yelling at karen in
the 1990 film
as the inspiration for the idea that
karen's are infuriating
i feel like dane cook made karen a thing
15 years ago every group has a karen
and she's always a bag of douche a
clearer connection to the modern day
meaning of karen can be found in the
2004
film mean girls when the airy karen asks
so if you're from africa why are you
white
oh my god karen you can't just ask
people why they're white it's also
possible
mean girls writer tina fey used the name
karen because it was already
in the public consciousness it's really
a what came first
chicken or the egg situation but long
before the name karen
became a pejorative the character type
had long been recognized by another name
according to georgia tech professor
andre brock during the time of slavery
black people used to refer to a white
woman exerting undue power over them as
a miss anne even after slavery there was
a general fear among the black community
that a white woman could easily make a
false or exaggerated accusation
and send a lynch mob after any
particular black man
given the black community's history of
interacting with the stereotype and the
popularity of the name
karen in a certain age bracket black
people started commonly referring to
these types of women as karen's
although the timeline is nebulous the
rise of smartphones and social media
further spread and popularized the term
has anyone ever called me a karen
pejoratively i don't think so
but i really wouldn't know i think i
don't fall into
the middle aged entitled white lady
category that karen's are usually
associated with
so no one's ever called me karen
pejoratively toward the end of the past
decade people were filming and posting
more incidents with cairns
it was common for each woman
perpetuating the incident to get her own
alliterative nickname for example in
2018 there was
permit patty a woman who called the cops
on an eight-year-old black girl
selling water without a permit there was
barbecue becky
this lady right here wants to sit here
and call the police on them for having a
barbecue at the lake as if this is not
normal
and she's like it's against the law i'm
gonna go home and call the police i'm
like you know what do what you want to
do i've been here 42 something years i
know where i
can and cannot barbecue i was walking by
and i saw her harassing him and stopped
he has done nothing he's been sitting
there chilling the entire time he's
really aggressive towards him there's
nothing to do with your race it seems
like a new gym pro going on because for
some reason every time i see it
black people are the ones targeted karen
incidents often include
a karen unnecessarily contacting the
police
in like middle school my friends and i
were
all over at my buddy's place for his
birthday
we all had like these airsoft guns but
they have like
fat orange tips on them shop tiny
plastic pellets or whatever like super
harmless
halfway through the party um this
woman comes out and like starts freaking
out about all these kids
and she called the cops it was like
really really scary because
i was the only black kid it definitely
could have ended
you know a lot differently a lot
differently
you know like you see a karen on the
internet like wilding out and
you don't really think twice or you
laugh about it but like in
other people's cases like they're
getting the police called on them
and then those situations escalate and
then people are getting hurt
uh karen is the person who calls the
police because quote unquote
you make them feel unsafe even though
you're not doing anything a carrot calls
your manager just because you're not
giving them what they want they're using
their identity
their their their privilege to their
advantage
often you'll see a karen harassing
service industry workers
so i used to work at a coffee shop so we
were super busy
i was the only one there so i used to
work as a
host for a very popular restaurant
called sugar fish and this one woman
she wanted to order a sandwich and she
asked me what type of bread it came on a
sourdough type of bread she goes oh can
i see it if there was any other day i
would love to do that for you but there
is a line at the door right now
and she was like well i don't want to
order it if i don't know what it looks
like
here comes karen and she's like hi there
i have a reservation for six
i talked to your manager on the phone he
said that y'all could sit and spread
away
but you were talking to me on the phone
you're trying to pull one on me is what
you're trying to say
i went to the person behind her started
taking their order and she was like no
like i don't want anyone else to order
before me like i'm it's my turn right
now she starts
yelling she's like this is horrible i
hate this establishment
and then she gets like a bunch of plates
she just smashes it down
and like the plates fall all over the
place you know there's food on the
ground
why would you do that who gives you the
right to think that
you have power over somebody else why i
would call that woman a karen
is because she kind of felt entitled
like oh everyone else can wait for me
like it's my turn now like
i'm the star of the show so i support
the karen memes
because it sheds light of kind of like
the privilege these people get
if you this white woman she can never do
anything wrong you know she's always
correct
i think it's really important to like
that we talk about it because
back then we didn't have karen's because
no one was recording any incidents
no one was recording any racism no one
was recording anything
so i feel like recording a karen
incident does bring
light to racism
the karen mean graduated from popularity
to virality with the onset of the
coronavirus pandemic
and the reinvigoration of the black
lives matter civil rights movement
google trends for karen from the last 12
months show an increase in searches
starting
around middle to late march the
coronavirus version of the karen meme
became particularly poignant in the
hellscape of 2012. where'd you get that
mess from
this karen refuses to wear a face mask
in public or in stores
harasses service industry workers and
spreads cobit 19 conspiracy theories
he is the manager i am rich
something you've never seen bye karen
the most cariny
karen however is amy cooper a new yorker
who called the cops and said a black
bird watcher was threatening her life
after he asked her to put her dog on a
leash that same day
george floyd was killed by minneapolis
police officers
people began linking the racism of
karen's like amy cooper to wider and
more lethal instances
of systemic racism and police brutality
but what do
karen's really think about their name
being used as a pejorative
i was a little upset a part of me really
did think about
who could i complain to
about this mean when the caramel started
gaining traction i was
horrified obviously because the name has
a negative connotation to it now and i
didn't really want people to associate
me
not liking the karen meme is something
a karen and a
karen would do when i first encountered
the karen meme
honestly i didn't even connect it to
myself
because i know that i'm not like that
uh you know i have a duty as like a good
karen to prove that there are exceptions
to the name
and it doesn't really bother me anymore
because i know the meme isn't
attacking my name per se but rather it's
labeling a certain type of person
we have a knack for turning our hurt to
humor but my only concern
would be that the karen meme just stays
a meme and it doesn't evolve
and it doesn't move towards any sort of
action in 2019
oregon passed a bill to punish racist
9-1-1 callers
attempting to put a stop to people like
the central park karen
in july a san francisco supervisor
introduced the karen act
which stands for caution against
racially exploitative non-emergencies
hopefully with some reflection and
change this type of racist person can be
a thing of the past
let's all work together and kill karen
i mean not the person uh
the need for the meme kill the need for
the meme
that the caring in quotes you get it
you get it i'll stop